[Music]
this is what an emergency department
sounds like in the grip of a pandemic
can i have
a big ghost please the stream of covet
patience is
constant
this man was brought in this morning his
multiple sclerosis has flared up
but doctors fear a sharp spike in his
temperature
could have been caused by a covid19
infection
[Music]
we're in the royal surrey county
hospitals emergency department
this area is exclusively for suspected
coveted 19 cases
it's been expanded but it keeps filling
up
we had doubled our numbers the
week just after christmas before the
end of the year and we are maintaining
and done numbers
so at the moment we haven't got any any
any feeling that
these is going to be to to slow down
we are prepared to to to to be like this
for the next four six weeks at least
that is a long way away a month and a
half
of unrelenting pressure to give you a
sense of how busy this
emergency department is since midnight
they've admitted 30 patients eight of
whom
are suspected covert 19 patients it's
only quarter past
three in the afternoon by midnight
tonight that figure
is expected to treble
some of the sickest patients are brought
here
this is a purpose-built high-dependency
covert 19
ward having this extra capacity
prevents the hospital from being
overwhelmed
[Music]
so she tested positive on the third of
january um but she came in she required
four leaders but has gone on straight
onto cpap so now she's on cpap 60 10.
it's it's it's relentless really the
admissions come
fast and they come all the time people
are sicker they're sicker now than they
were in the first wave
very much so sicker younger and of
course once you're sicker you're going
to be in hospital for a long period of
time
and then you can't really always predict
which way things are going to go
and we're seeing some very tragic
situations of course and we are seeing
patients who did have gatherings over
christmas or new years which were
allowed
but we're now seeing the the after
effects of that and it brings a lot of
guilt and emotion of course with it
david is one of these young patients
he's just a teenager
yeah only 19. yeah it
shows that you can get like anyone can
get it like anyone at all and then
as you can tell by the seriousness i'm
having to be on oxygen
i've been an oxygen since the time i've
been here i haven't had any
medical issues really and
all of a sudden i could be like this in
a bed um
in a hospital stricken down not being
able to do anything
because of this virus like it's it's
terrible
you worry about how you're going to get
better at
any long-term effects oh of course like
it
it goes around my head like this could
this could potentially damage my lungs a
bit
this could potentially stop me doing
stuff that i want to do the peak in
hospital admissions
is still a week to 10 days away
according to the government
so beds do not stay vacant for long
since we've opened we are very busy we
are going in
one patient and one patient back in
again so it's in and out constantly
for us we're kind of viewing it as you
know we're almost in a tunnel
we know that there's a light there we
just can't quite see it yet and that
darkness is being felt
across the country not just for nurses
like elaine
but for youngsters like david two who'll
worry about the impact of covid19
on their health for years to come ashish
joshi sky news
at the royal surrey county hospital